foreign
[Music]
thank you
very much
[Music]
I'll be right on the Gemini
we're getting left on my room
very soon
[Music]
they took it right he's got a close gym
behind him now
copy behind
thank you
[Music]
we're going eastbound on the bill now I
can't stand
[Music]
foreign
COPD
[Music]
foreign
behind me
I promise
[Music]
too fast too fast
too fast
left lane we're cutting back across to
the right
[Music]
s
coming back over now let's see in money
left hand lane left hand lane right here
right in front of me
take him out
[Music]
fell down
to 82.
[Music]
82 right now
traffic here going uh West 182 West 182.
[Music]
before seven years down to 82. right
here for 16 Pursuit heavy traffic on 82.
[Music]
go ahead with it
continue to pursue until Aviation gets
there any opportunity to hit we need to
take it
easy
42 82 going west 73 miles an hour
all green lights so far coming through
here
[Music]
he was approaching 42. Elementary School
75 mile an hour E.T westbound still
[Music]
traffic like next intersection
come out Jones
[Music]
we're all 20 right now going east 20
East 20 East coming into the area right
now 20 in the construction zone
[Music]
83 and 20.
are we on 20
.
[Music]
17-21's out
by gunpoint
s
get out of there show me your head
let's go
thank you
[Music]
very much
Gracie take over radio traffic please
[Music]
South on
fenmore
say that again
Southbound on Benmore Benmore
[Music]
okay
Northbound on South westbound on Charles
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
on Elder
Mario
[Music]
now heading south on Wallace Street
westbound on Michigan right now
westbound on Michigan
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Southwest
still on Michigan
[Music]
you got another roller video
is that in the incoming traffic now
[Music]
awesome
I've been relaying it
[Music]
hurry up
the westbound in Michigan
[Music]
Stadium Drive now
Stadium Drive
out eastbound on Academy Street
[Music]
thank you
rotation foreign
[Music]
I lost him here for a sec
I'm on Westnedge
I think he went on Park
[Music]
all right he's uh running right there
that's the car on Park
[Music]
thank you
I believe
[Music]
where is he
right here
this is
go to the gas station
[Music]
you used to be advised he stopped here
at the intersection
stop
[Music]
I've got spike strips I got spike strips
he's been spiked
[Music]
oh your buddy's good by the way
appreciate that feeling
so y'all ran because of the weed y'all
ran because of the weed
come in
that would probably just been a ticket
just giving you a heads up
5 30 Cleveland I'm not worth it
okay
what's your 39 80.
[Music]
29.
you throw up
[Music]
we're still rolling
it is 228.8
until the state five Tom four five x-ray
eight
[Music]
we're still going 229.
I'll be there at 64.
[Music]
you need us to go for you and is there
any local PD nearby
[Music]
CD can be in contact with them 229.6
speed is 63.
40 for 5 30.
229.8
[Music]
a black Mercedes SUV
30 speed is 64.
I think seven eight has a sergeant out
if you get patches with them
you're good
[Music]
traffic conditions
230.4
[Music]
7 miles an hour it's clear traffic's
light
[Music]
230.6 we're starting to slow down we're
going 38.
um
[Music]
yeah
are they still driving signal 100
negative
31.
[Music]
looks like he's trying to look for a
crossover football going west
foreign
[Music]
traffic
is like
[Music]
5 30 70s
70.
[Music]
we'll try the North West Virginia
for West Virginia
[Music]
thank you
oh
my God
[Music]
29 plus speeds
around 80 to 28.8
[Music]
um
75.
[Music]
foreign
tires are flat
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
and a CRP
[Music]
let me see your hands put your hands out
the window
step outside of the window
step outside
face on the direction but get your hands
in the air hands in the air now
turn around
walk back to the sound Bible turn around
in the air turn around why I can't think
you're flying right now
face that direction raise that direction
get on your knees
get on the ground hands out
cross your legs
dispatch Claire
is there anyone around it
because
that's it that's it
foreign
I know
17.
they're going to bail here at Northpoint
the state I got the driver
[Music]
Conway uh interesting
thank you
so we're going to be heading Northbound
Northbound on
Abram Brook passing uh
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]